now typically in the times of old maybe
the women would have a shorter skirt
maybe show their ankles or maybe
slightly more revealing clothing while
they were searching and trying to
attract the husband but they knew once
they got married you were expected to
dress and act differently no you are not
expected to act the exact same way
before you get married and after you get
married once you are a married woman you
were expected to not put yourself in
certain situation ations and not appear
as if you are looking or appear to be
attracting attention for other men your
family's honor is very important but
modern women do not care and I'm seeing
this phenomenon of women trying to get
attention from other men in their 50s
second half of your life isn't supposed
to be about sex